so how can someone know whether they've
gotten lost in other voices and are
trying to emulate another show another
writer because maybe they think oh yeah
this is me too but really they're
copying True Blood or they're you know
it's it's almost like the the girl in
high school who wants to be like the
popular girl yes and so she starts
dressing like her and trying to do her
hair like her but really she's not being
who she really needs to be she's trying
to be somebody who seems popular and
wanted when you know we all want to be
successful and one of the ways we we
find success is to look at other people
and say oh I could pick I can I like the
way she looks so I'm gonna look like her
I like the way he writes so I'm going to
write like her and you hear all these
stories of like even Joan Didion who
copied Ernest Hemingway in order to find
her voice but what you want to do but
you know you're on the wrong track if
you if you start feeling that anxiety
that I could never be like her that I'm
oh when I compare myself to his writing
I'm just really not I and you start
feeling that that sense of not good
enough not meeting something and you
start wanting to be seen you can feel
that pull of wanting to be seen like
your Idol right and and that's the
moment where you know if you were
talking about a physical look you'd go
get plastic surgery right so I could put
her nose on my face
so I can put his words in my script or
my story and so when you start feeling
that you have to recognize that you're
walking away from yourself you're
walking away from yourself and trying to
sit in somebody else's image and if you
do that you will always be a shadow of
someone else the truth of who you are
the reason that you came to write won't
come out
it won't flourish it's kind of like
you'll you'll be that that that plant
that just doesn't get enough water and
doesn't get enough Sun so it might bloom
but the flower will be small and the
fruit will be bitter right and if you're
really gonna anchor in yourself you have
to believe that you are as brilliant as
as the person you want to be and so
you're going to appreciate how they
shine but you're not going to copy how
they shine you want to appreciate how
strong they are in their voice and you
want to practice your own voice as
loudly as you can
now the awkward thing is you're going to
practice that voice and it's not going
to be good right we're never good when
we start playing the piano we're never
great when we start driving we crash
into things right if it takes practice
but you have to hang on to the belief so
this is the disconnect you have to know
that even though you may not look good
at what you're doing get what you're
doing is not accomplishing the vision of
what you want to accomplish ultimately
you have to believe that you're gonna
get there just as you are
so it's hanging on to the tension of
being not so good an amateur
awkward but believing that you're gonna
grow into something that will flourish
and bloom and you're gonna have to have
patience and that's the most difficult
thing because when you're when you're
struggling and you want success and you
know you're good but it's not coming
there's a tendency to say what I'm on
the wrong path the universe doesn't want
me to do this I should go to that path I
should follow that path anchor in this
is where meditation becomes really
important and really knowing that
there's a there are stories inside of
you that need to be told just the way
you want to tell them and having the
patience to wait for them to bloom so
that the timing is right and that your
timing is right as an artist and that
timing is right in the marketplace
you